to get to the point oh yeah you know Kim
Kardashian and Megan to stallion Kanye
West tweeting about anime like you got
to go through like a lot of like lowbrow
eat mariner cultural stuff like waka
flocka being like suck my Dragonball
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from toonami classics like Naruto and
Dragonball Z to the films of Makoto
Shinkai
and Studio Ghibli food has always been a
massively important part of the anime
viewing experience
sushi ramen omurice takoyaki somehow
these incredibly delicious meals are
made to look even more appealing when
scarf down by our favorite characters
when you want to animate do watch and
English for Japanese yeah Japanese but
today I'm going back to the source
material I'm heading to Japanese
bookstore Kinokuniya for a manga
shopping spree with rapper and comic
book obsessive Denzel curry I wanted to
hear more about denzil's favorite titles
and better understand hip hop's deep
appreciation for Japanese animation
[Music]
Denzel it's pretty clear after just even
meeting you for two minutes that you
love anime I'm super Andy what would you
say you're most into right now what are
you watching right now one punch man
definitely very nice and you can tell
from your music that anime and manga
play a really huge inspirational role
I'd say how did you first get into it
when how did it start mixing with well
music let's take it back to our legit
boy when me and my brother in the room
and basically my 3 o'clock get out of
school we'll go straight to watching
toonami
no homework nothing you just keep
watching it that's when it was playing
all the oldies Goldie's like I'm talking
about like Big O girls playing toys he
was playing Dragon Ball Z it was playing
Dragon Ball and then I remember I got it
- oh you hakusho but but it was on Adult
Swim frozen that was like the first time
I ever seen carton was cursing yeah
seriously and then when they put it on
tsunami from there so my love for
enemies started to grow and grow and
grow long guys they doing martial arts
in that dish
so have you ever noticed how Goku and
basically anybody that trains how they
eat food they eat a lot of rice blonde
ramen see a lot of beef in there a lot
yeah and a lot of like turkey leg like
chicken leg
I feel like food in manga anime is drawn
and depicted so well it always makes me
really hungry and I also love that
there's this kind of sequence of
everybody just shoving food in their
mouths like I'm training so therefore I
need to consume energy yeah but that's
the point like I remember when I was on
working out like every day I'll just eat
yeah and add that forever yeah yeah and
he's like okay go on stage get off eat
again go to sleep why do you think
hip-hop and rap culture references one
punch man
Dragon Ball Z Naruto anime stuff all the
time a lot of people reference that
because you know there's a lot of bars
you can put into it but this is like
what we came up on you know you see how
the RZA the GZA everybody whose hand
clan came up on a wu-tang collection
Cowboy Bebop Samurai shampoo drug mozi
this is our wu-tang collection yeah you
know it's just what we grew up on and we
want to be powerful would be good at
something a little bit of mess and
whatever you want to do so that's why I
feel like we resonate with anime a lot
because there's a lot of character
development and it helps us where our
development as a child
[Music]
we talked about my favorite animes so I
want to talk about your favorite oh
thank you so much I would say a lot of
my stuff changes depending on the season
and I kind of want to keep a variety but
very into food anime lately food looks
so good it's delicious
very appetizing yeah and I feel like
they do a really good job depicting
everyday Japanese food I have you heard
of for doors though I haven't really
okay so it's a surprise it's actually
really interesting because shokugeki
kinda takes the angle of that shiro
journey but with food so this kid goes
to like a culinary school and it's like
life or death okay so it follows that
kind of DBZ mentality where there's
always a stronger better chef yeah how
many chefs have better than him well a
lot he's at the very bottom oh I feel
like this is like this is like give you
anxiety why was he at the bottom he's
not he sucks I think you know he's just
young and he's new and you're in an
elite culinary school and he's like a
street rat well ma'am I like this I like
this
I'm so excited please think it's wrong
another food manga and anime that's
really popular that showcases really
good Japanese food is sweetness and
lightening and it's about a single
father who tries to figure out how to
raise his daughter be suddenly having to
be the one
and takes care of the house it's
incredible because they also give you a
little recipes in the middle of the
manga showing you how the dad figured
out how to kind of create this dish and
recreate it for his daughter it's really
sweet so yeah this is like the complete
opposite side of shokugeki few words for
you stay-at-home dads
I recommend this all right now that
we've kind of established our anime
knowledge a little bit and I know you're
an artist as well let's go draw some
anime you don't want to do this let's go
meet my friend Masako okay
[Music]
reading about food and manga is one
thing but knowing how to draw it is
another misako rocks is the best-selling
author and illustrator behind manga
titles like bounce back and biker girl
Denzel has been hard at work on his own
comic book for months but we're meeting
up with music oh so I can finally learn
how to draw like a true manga master so
pretty much a we gonna draw more like a
Girl Scout the manga cafe with a shiny
hair yes oh ma nice
yeah coloring yes the only one and I
really like to see how you're gonna draw
your awesome male character so let's do
this thing
so the farcical a I'm going to draw like
circle cross lines but then the side
lines a little lower of yes cuz it's a
manga character and a female so you
wanna do really big eyes than the key so
that's how you wanna draw a little yell
or yeah gotcha
okay then neckline hold on the same time
so much that's super fast okay we're
gonna try to catch up I know you're
working on your own manga right now
producing and illustrating and writing
and doing everything with it can you
tell us a little bit about that
basically the manga that I'm working on
right now is called black metal tears
and I'm drawing basically the main
character of it right now
the dude name is Octavius Octavius Jones
jr. but you just call them Oh Jake his
character is somebody who's trying to
start robots from life just taking over
the whole plant initiative because it's
like a post-apocalyptic future right now
you know me being a fan of anime and
just like coming up with stories my
whole life and the way I do my albums I
wanted to be like a story that people
gonna be like didn't sign it over I love
in the muscle
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so now me moving on Sosa's
like you know like a moon that you to go
yeah gonna come on so that kind of uh
yeah exactly
speaking of it very excited now maybe we
can just put like a punk out
are there any anime or manga that kind
of stick out to you in regards to how
well they animated depict food I
personally like like Ghibli and yeah
Jamie I mean they're like whatever they
just make it especially like a bread
yeah even like a sound hmm
yeah the way that's regular work yeah
punk cake you know kick its delivery
service yeah so definitely yeah Jubilee
how making me hungry
[Music]
so we're gonna try to do it back yeah
make this one more nice it looks super
water to be that laughs all right so now
usually the cute kawaii one normalizer
is we're gonna put you know they put so
maybe we can just draw a cute cat face
yes perfect I got ears yeah yeah okay
alright so now almost done doing that
just to quickly maybe speech from yes
okay yes and then let's say oh is she
oh yeah sound like oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
while Denzil finishes his drawing misako
and i are ready for lunch at high collar
where some iconic anime dishes have
found their way onto the menu we're
meeting the hilarious comedian Zac Fox
and a Grammy award-winning musician
Thundercat together Zac and Thundercat
are two of the biggest anime junkies I
know and the perfect people to share a
cartoon themed feast with hi guys thank
you so much for joining me cute we're
here at high collar which is my friend
cicadas restaurant where they serve some
iconic dishes that you see popping up in
anime all the time and our first dish is
over ice have you ever seen over ice in
anime I'm like a lot of food and anime I
just be looking at doing stuff flying
every day yeah just like and it looks so
yeah I mean I would watch anime so here
at high collar they mix tomato-based
fried rice with bacon and then they top
it with an omelet egg which is generally
how it's done in Japan as well it
normally comes dressed in ketchup it's
treated a lot like latte art is where
it's just kind of dependent on your chef
or depending on what kind of restaurant
urine and we were specifically asked for
the ketchup bottle so we could make our
own memories aren't perfect like to draw
[Music]
Wow miss Akane isn't a cat in the
coochie exactly
oh this is fantastic I'm glad you like
it
I literally always wish like I want to
wander the forest and then slip into
another realm I can't have anyone on me
yeah blowing up in Atlanta like it's
around about this back culture but
seeing like the influence it was flooded
with that specifically African American
culture yeah and a lot of the even pop
culture in Japan is like there's a very
big connecting thing that happens my
honest opinion about it is it has to do
with relating in such a higher point
it's almost like it is inexplicable
because it is the finer point of
whatever that is you know there was like
definite life force bringing the two
together and my gosh I could slap
somebody
that good guy
[Music]
like no like there's like my but they're
not and then 2016 happens in this like
everybody widespread and noisiest like
the perfect the multiplication yeah
American rock culture
I'm sorry this is amazing I know you're
enjoying it but save some room because
we got some yeah another iconic Japanese
I mean not a survivable right
[Music]
[Music]
we have some japanese-style pancake
snacks in Japanese they actually call it
hook the claim to make pot cakes like a
cookie baking in a huff again a digit
rating boy
oh my god
are there any hot cakes you saw in anime
like are there any iconic ones that you
remember I mean I was I think it might
like like Simpson like that since and I
definitely saw something like yeah that
makes sense eternity it appeals to
children so that's what makes that um we
were talking about how we saw it a lot
in Ghibli movie because agent food so
well and especially having like the
syrup it's almost like a device to make
it look listening yeah really off the
animation for that like a moment the
attention they pay to the food to
animate now it's like absurd it's
amazing and I think that's what's so
great about anime like I know it's
considered a cartoon and obviously it is
in Japan as well but it's made not for
children it's made for literally all
ages like it's just entertainment and it
doesn't matter that it's drawn it
doesn't necessarily mean it's made for
any age range so that's why you see the
level of violence and then you see
something that kind of appeals to like
mothers who stay at home and I feel like
food is such a natural connector with
people it's like the great equalizer
everybody enjoys food but you got you
got to eat and gotta enjoy it so I feel
that anime really learn to capitalize on
being like I know what you like like eat
food
yeah that's that's good stuff man that's
just good good enemy
[Music]
well thank you guys so much for joining
us today did you enjoy the food yet is
butter taste okay is it kind of how
you'd expect it after seeing it in anime
like that's probably what it's like
saying that they're making water it
always deliver yeah I feel great sunny
Phoenix thank you so much for joining us
guys thank you thank you for having us
this is delicious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for watching Gocha gig
I so appreciate it Sean should they like
and subscribe like and subscribe or else
thank you